good morning good afternoon and welcome
everyone to today's live broadcast
utilizing
rapid diagnostics and new methods to
quickly diagnose sepsis
i'm alexis cross of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lappert
and sponsored by broker daltonix for
more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
brooker.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
like to now introduce our presenter
francis yangboa
laboratory manager microbiology and
virology
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
francis you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
hello everyone um so thank you for
coming to my presentation today
um so my name is francis jean-black and
i am the laboratory manager at great
ormond street hospital for children
and microbiology department um so i'm
the laboratory manager and i'm a trainee
consultant clinical scientist
and today my presentation is focusing on
utilizing rapid diagnostics and new
methods to quickly diagnose sepsis
um specifically looking at moldy tof
um so just to give you an agenda for my
presentation and how it's going to go so
just a bit of a short introduction to
the hospital i work
so that's great ormond street hospital
and also how we kind of implemented the
moldy top biotype of workflow into gosh
and to the microbiology department
and i'm going to talk about sepsis as
well and then also talk about
other parts of moldy toff that we've
been incorporated and looking to
incorporate so
how we've incorporated the mbt sepsi
type ibd kit
and i've also got some case studies to
look at how it actually has benefited
patients
i'm also looking at validation of the
sepsis hyper and a
rapid workflow and also quick resistance
testing by the mbt star carbo ibd kit
and then just kind of summary at the end
and
so but here's a few details about the
hospital i work at so i work at great
ormond street hospital in london so
many of you probably heard of this
hospital um it is a famous international
children's hospital
and it was invested in by charles weston
in 14th of february 1852 which is
valentine's day
we have 389 beds
and as well as kind of helping children
in the uk there are a number of children
that are actually come from
internationally from abroad to the
hospital for special treatment so it's a
specialized center where
patients come for bone marrow transplant
specialist operations and we have some
of the most
uh specialist medics and clinicians in
our
hospital with father foreign knowledge
of rare diseases so
this is just a picture of um great
ormond street so
this is from the london olympics 2012
and
um they actually marked the ceremony by
doing a little
performance when it was in london and
that's actually when i started working
in the hospital so
you know we have patients that come in
for specialist treatment we also get
children with very rare diseases
and there is an international hospital
where we get children from all over the
world
so just a bit of information about the
department that i actually
work in so i work in the microbiology
department i'm the lab manager
and we receive 125 000 tests per year
and this is all mainly culture based so
we
receive a number of different uh
clinical specimens from urines
to swabs swabs from wound sites
deep wounds and sterile body fluids such
as
css cerebrospinal fluids
and tissue enteric specimens
and we also do virology testing for
testing for viruses too but i
specifically look after the
microbiology and bacteriology section
and within our department we have 40
healthcare scientists
so this is a mixture of different skill
bases so we've got what we call
biomedical scientists
who actually do the kind of diagnostic
work on the benches and actually analyze
the bacteria on the agar plates
and identify them and set up
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
we also have 11 members of support staff
who actually
um prepare specimens so this again is
the culturing of specimens onto
agar incubating plates
and so they kind of prepare that work
for the biomedical scientists to read
we also have clinical scientists um so
i'm both a clinical scientist and a
biomedical scientist
who also participate in research so the
hospital is actually quite
research focused and we try and develop
to kind of make a better outcome for
patients
and so we have been looking at moldy
soft quite a bit in you know
incorporating and
improving things so as i said
in the microbiology department we have
bacterial identification
tests and antibiotic susceptibility
tests
um and eight years ago things were quite
different
from where they are now so we used to do
a lot of bacterial identification tests
so this would be a routine test such as
a staff
latex test or an oxidase test a ground
film
to kind of get an identification of
organisms um
at the time eight years ago we had a
vitex which we use for species
identification but generally we use
mainly uh actual identification tests
how's that the hospital capacity tends
is increasing and we kind of need to
meet with demand and there's a need for
improvement for faster species
identification
um and it was looked at what is the best
way of trying to kind of
improve our workflow so that actually we
can get results out
more quickly and not just for the lab
and but for patients too so actually we
can try and you know
get a result out more quickly or if we
can get information to a clinician more
quickly
they are able to act and kind of you
know either carry out necessary
treatment management or
an infection prevention control measure
so that actually they can help that
patient and so we then looked at the
multitask biotype and looking to kind of
bring this into our department
so i mean there were a number of reasons
we wanted to bring the moldy top biotype
in um firstly we kind of wanted to
improve the workflow
just to you know if you have an
identification before you set up your
susceptibility testing actually it's
better you can also report that
to the medics before you have any kind
of results so that if they need to take
any
quick action they can do um also to get
accurate diagnosis as well because i
mean some of the biochemical tests we
used previously
you know you can only get it to species
level you couldn't actually get that
um actual identification what it was
specifically
also improving turnaround time as well
so i mean having
you know the biochemicals that we had
before previously
we used to you know do a test and have
maybe a rough idea what it was but then
sometimes the susceptibility testing
might need to be changed
further once you have that id so
actually having a correct id at the
beginning made a big difference
so this is just a picture of our moldy
top in the lab and we've named her
bonnie
so um mold it off at gosh so
implementation so yes the we decided
after uh
managing to put in a charity bid that we
were awarded
uh to actually bring in a moldy top
biotyper into great ormond street
hospital
and this was implemented in 2013.
so we carried out a big validation
looking at 500
samples so these are basically bacterial
isolates
which we put through different tests so
some had gone through
biochemical tests but then also i've
gone through 60 less pcr which we're
fortunate actually to have in house so
um you know for any kind of rare
organisms we managed to put it that we
had sword we they'd gone through 16 sp
for our validation and also sequencing
and we also at the time had our vitec
as well so the change
and so incorporating the mbt has changed
the workflow by reducing the time to
getting a result by at least 24 hours so
again with biochemical tests or even the
vitec
you would prepare a suspension put that
id on but you wouldn't get it till the
next day
and so actually having the moldy top at
great ormond street has really improved
things because
you know once your culture is grown you
can actually identify the bacteria
fairly quickly
you know within a minute and then you
can actually adapt what sensitivities
you do
do you actually need to carry out any
sensitivities um and as
i mentioned before there was a benefit
for clinicians and for our patients
because the mbt has improved time to
result from clinicians
and has helped to improve antimicrobial
stewardship so actually
when a medic knows that you know they've
got a result
um on a patient they can actually change
their treatment fairly quickly before
you even have any antibiotic results so
that's quite key
and so something that i really want to
focus on is actually sepsis
sepsis is a hidden killer and sepsis
results from an overreaction of the
body's immune system to infection
where our own tissues and organs are
attacked it can lead to septic shock
multi-organ failure and death so sepsis
strikes
an estimated 30 million people worldwide
every year and many of whom die or
suffer from permanent health issues
globally the mortality rate of patients
with sepsis is greater than a third
and in the u.s sepsis accounts for far
more deaths than a number of deaths from
prostate cancer breast cancer and aids
uh combined so obviously this kind of
information it is quite
a serious killer um and you know i think
there's a lot that's being done to try
and improve
treatment for patients and management so
just
kind of giving a picture from the uk so
as i've said it is a serious clinical
condition um and within the uk 123 000
cases of sepsis are diagnosed per year
which is quite a lot so but in the uk we
have
our own guidelines um in terms of sepsis
and we have what's called the sepsis six
guidelines which is for quick
treatment and management and so it's
trying to basically diagnose a patient
before you know it gets too late so
obviously they've got six
uh guidelines for the sepsis six and if
the patient
shows those symptoms then basically we
need to kind of act quickly
so one of the key points of the sepsis
six is actually collection of blood
cultures and rapid identification of
pathogens
so within our department in our hospital
and in london
we basically try to get you know if they
suspect a patient has sepsis
one of the first things is to get a
blood culture to the laboratory as
quickly as possible
and get it onto our blood culture
machine so that actually
we can then you know if it is positive
we can get a result as quickly as
possible
and so yeah one of the key points is
collection of blood cultures and rapid
identification
of pathogens um and we
you know we are always striving to
improve and we wanted to try and improve
identification of positive
blood cultures and so from a research
side we wanted to try and look at
incorporating the mbt separately typo
kit
um so with this kit basically
it looks that it can give you when a
blood culture flags up positive
you can use this kit to get a quick
identification of the organism
that is present within that blood
culture and that's really key
because it can do things such as improve
antibiotic prescribing
um and so you know by having that result
earlier
you can switch treatment on a patient
really quickly which i think they found
very beneficial
um it improves patient treatment and
management by early adoption of
antibiotic therapy
so this in the picture you can just see
that that's just what the kit is
um and it has different parts and it has
a lysis buffer
which actually breaks down the red blood
cells um and basically you concentrate
the organism down
so this is just kind of an idea of how
the mbt sepsi type
ibt kit works this is something that
we've incorporated into our laboratory
so
as i mentioned previously blood cultures
we get
from the ward and we've kind of had a
pre-analytical project to try and get
blood cultures to the laboratory as
quickly as possible
so you know if a patient they suspect
sepsis basically the blood culture is
collected
and it's put on to the blood culture
system as soon as possible
so if the blood culture flags are
positive within our laboratory we've
actually tried to incorporate
the mbt sepsis type so our algorithm of
workflow looks at that if the blood
culture flags are positive
and it's a new blood culture so it's the
first time a patient has had one
we then would go to the mbt sepsi type
um in order to try and get an
identification so
using the sepsi type of kit we basically
take
one microliter of blood from the
positive blood culture
and then add the lysis buffer we then
basically spin it down and you'll see
the concentrated bacterial organism at
the bottom
um it basically goes through a number of
steps before going on to
the moldy toss identification so then
after
being preprocessed through the sexy type
of kit it then goes through the
mbt compass um and sepsi type of module
where it is then analyzed and gives you
an identification
um so this has been really really key so
just a bit here the nbt sexy type of kit
selectively destroys blood cells and
enriches microorganisms from a
positively flagged blood culture
the resulting cell extracts and pellets
are suitable for analysis
using the multi-top bi-typer the mbt
said to type ibdk enables a highly
probable identification of the relevant
microorganism species within 15 to 20
minutes using the multitype
multi bi typer um so
yeah we have incorporated it into our
lab and actually we have seen
some patient benefits especially from
our clinicians when we kind of
communicated it
so after kind of validating the tests we
um you know have seen
looked at kind of clinical audit to see
how it's improved patient benefit
um so this is just a case study i'd like
to go over this is from
actually one of our patients so as i've
said with our patient population
we have it's children but also children
with rare diseases so we also get
neutropenic patients so these are
immunological immunological patients or
cancer patients who are referred to the
hospital so
this is a case study about a patient
that came in and they were a neutropenic
patient and they had a blood culture to
flag up positive
so at the point what we would have done
in our previous algorithm is actually
set up
a ground film and looked and if it was
gnr we would have then set up a direct
sensitivity which
would have been read the next day and
looking at the clinical history of the
patient there was no kind of history of
colonization and the patient was put on
meripenin
and so it's kind of a different story
when the sepsis type then comes in
so basically sepsis type was used on
this patient for their blood culture
um and then actually when the mbt sexual
type or ibd was performed
um we've managed to get an
identification of stenotrophomonas
multiphenia
so actually this is quite crucial i mean
firstly there was a correct antibiotic
prescribing on the nbtc type of result
so having that result meant the result
was phone to the ward and then
immediately they could change so then
the patient then
changed their treatment to better print
self um
section to a higher dose to actually
clear that organism because
again the patient was on meuropenin but
as many of us know stenotrophomonas
multiple is actually resistant to
murupenin
so it's a clinical benefit and actually
having that result meant that that
antibiotic switch can be done so much
more quickly so actually it shows the
benefit of sexual hyper
and actually that was one case study
which the medics at in our hospital
actually noted that actually quite
significant so yeah it was really key
and shows
how crucial sex type has been in our
department
and just another case study just to show
how um
sexy type has helped us so we had an
intensive care unit patient
come in and again they had a spiked
temperature
and raised crp and so blood cultures
were taken and they were sent to the
laboratory
the blood cultures actually flagged up
positive um in the ground film was grand
positive cockeyed
clusters and so the patient was started
on vancomycin
and again when the blood culture flagged
up positive at the same time i as doing
the ground film
the healthcare scientists then set up
this sepsi type
test so they says have an nbt eclectic
hyper
so that was performed and then we
managed to get an identification of
staphylococcus aureus
so within our patient population we
mainly do see quite a bit of staff
and species so staff ep capitalists and
staff focus oil to know it may be more
common to have bacteremias within
adult hospitals within our hospital it's
not so common
but actually when we do get staph aureus
um
september bacteremia it's actually quite
significant
so you know having that id so much
earlier because we wouldn't have got
that it was a staff always until the
next day when the plates were looked at
and we've done this by a chemical test
actually having it at the beginning was
quite crucial because then
the result was phoned to the awards the
intensive care unit
um and then prompting early line removal
which is key
and also um changing kind of management
of the patient and
the treatment kept the same but actually
there was also change
the line was removed more quickly and
that was more change in their management
so sexy type has been really really good
and i have to say it has been quite
beneficial
um but we are always looking to improve
wherever we can always trying to you
know
improve patient benefit and clinical
benefit for the patient
and so it was a couple of years ago that
we
were due to get a new blood culture
machine and we needed to kind of carry
out a new validation of this blood
culture machine to check that it was
working appropriately
um so at the same time it's getting our
blood culture machine we also have to
kind of revalidate the sepsis hyper
and then at that point we decided to
actually look at maybe changing
the actual workflow of this sepsi typer
and looking at a rapid
workflow so why why is there need to
improve and simplify the workflow well i
think the key thing for us so
although the mbt sepsis typer it is a
really good kit
it is quite hands-on and so we try to
look at a way of
trying to actually reduce the hands-on
time um
i think this is particularly key with
our um
staff so within our laboratory as i said
in
my earlier side we've got a team of 40
and we rotate to cover a 24-hour system
so there are actually
a healthcare science is working at night
but it is only one healthcare scientist
working at night time
um and so when they're working alone if
they have positive blood culture and
it's a new one and they need to do the
nbt
sepsis type but it can be quite hands-on
and sometimes when your own
when you're on your own in the lab and
there are other duties going on it can
be quite hectic so
to try and reduce that pressure on our
lab staff
but also getting a lot more quickly to
the ward is quite a benefit so
while carrying out the validation of our
new blood culture system
so we looked at 80 blood culture bottles
which were spiked so we used horse blood
and spiked it with a dilution of control
organism
and um as you can see here we used
six control organisms um staphylococcus
aureus staphylococcus epidermidis
entrococcus
fecalis uh pseudomonas originator
uh e coli and typical and ammonii and
for the control organisms we spiked 10
to 15 bottles this is a mixture of
pediatric aerobic bottles and
anaerobic bottles and what we tried to
do
is and basically set these bottles up on
the machine to prove that firstly they
could be detected by the blood culture
machine
but then once they had flagged up
positive to then actually carry out
a sepsi typer and what we did is
actually compare
the two sepsi typo methods so it was the
actual sepsi typing method that you know
comes
with the actual kit and then actually a
reduced sepsi typo
method a rapid workflow so out of the 80
blood cultures they all managed to flag
up as
positive um and then we carried out the
sexy typer so
out 78 out of the 80 or the positive
blood cultures identified by the sexy
type or ibd
kit two of the samples uh had not
identified by the staphylococcus
epidermidis
and at this point we also decided to
compare the mbt sexy type of ibt
extraction method
so this is the standard workflow with
the rapid workflow
so just to give you an idea about the
rapid workflow and how this kind of
differs from the current one standard
workflow so the workflow starting
you know with a positive blood culture
so once it's flagged up positive
you harvest one mil of the blood culture
liquid into an eppendorf tube
and you then add lysis buffer and
basically mix
so you can like vortex it and then you
centrifuge it down for two minutes
and you discard the supernatant you then
add a washing buffer and mix for 30
seconds and then centrifuge
down again and discard the supernatant
and basically you are left with a pellet
now
for the routine standard workflow it
would then go through a different number
of kind of filtering processes to
basically make it more clearer so then
it goes
through uh 70 ethanol washing with water
and but what we decided that actually
the bacterial organism is concentrated
in that pellet
and so rather than doing those
additional steps to actually just
use that pellet directly to identify the
organism so
that pellet that concentrated after
you've done the wash
and we then would basically touch and
put it directly onto
a moldy tof uh target plate and so
that's kind of the rapid
separate type of workflow and
so yeah it's basically it is much more
shorter
so we did a comparison between the two
methods so it was the
rapid sexy type of workflow and then the
standard workflow
and so the standard workflow all full
extraction you can see here that
basically 78 out of the 80
positive blood cultures managed to id
now hands on time so this is the
operator time that the healthcare
scientists
actually will spend is about 20 to 30
minutes
and with the rapid workflow so this is
again the same blood cultures that's
like that positive
and we tested 76 out of the 80
managed to correctly identify with the
rapid workflow
um and the hands-on time was 10 to 15
minutes so actually that's quite
significant
you know it's only two that didn't
manage to identify from the rapid
workflow and those were
for all of them it's actually the
staphylococcus epidermis that we had an
issue in terms of identifying
so i think we can actually see quite a
few benefits from here
so the key benefits you know of the kit
and of the rapid workflow so using the
rapid blood flow firstly
we reduce hands-on time so the rapid
workflow's showing reduce hands-on
time to 10-15 minutes where previously
it was 20 to 30 minutes and
for my team that's quite crucial because
actually
especially when you're working at
nighttime so they're in the lab on their
own
and then their blood culture flags up
and then there might be something that
comes from theaters
having that reduced time actually helps
in terms of you know
you're not stressed and that you can
actually focus and get a result more
quickly so it's quite beneficial
um reduce time to diagnosis so compared
to the previous method you know also
ground film the mbt
sepsi type or ibd workflow has reduced
the diagnosis
up to 24 hours so i mean looking at both
methods generally it has
you know really improved things greatly
because
you know having that id we are managing
to change a lot i mean
improved antimicrobial prescribing and
that's something we are trying to drive
within our hospital
is improving prescribing habits so that
actually patients are on the correct
antibiotic at the right time
so the mbt sepsis hyper ivd workflow has
improved antimicrobial prescribing
behaviors
ensures patient receives correct
treatment immediately
um i guess we are all aware of these
hard times cobia 19 and you know within
our hospital it's been quite an issue as
well
and the importance of the mbt sexy type
you know has been critical especially in
the intensive care units where you know
a patient develops a temperature
fever and actually you know getting a
definition diagnosed
quickly is quite crucial so you know
laboratory tests a number of tests will
be done and they will be sent to the lab
trying to get a result of what is wrong
with the patient and so
again if you can different get a
differential diagnosis that actually
the raised temperature is caused because
of sepsis that's quite key so
yes in these hard times it is quite
crucial
um so i will just talk a bit more about
kind of moldy
biotite future development so you know
future i think is quite bright in terms
of
multitop and how we will actually use it
i mean we
we've been very impressed by moldy topic
over the last eight years it's done so
much for us and
sexy type of the rapid workflow and
there's quite a lot you know
we are all about kind of patient benefit
within our laboratory and so
if we are able to kind of improve
diagnosis uh get results out more
quickly
then that's great for our patients um so
as i mentioned before we're
an international hospital we get
patients from all over
um and i think something that we're
quite aware of is kind of colonization
of patients with
this organism so you know
with this carbopylamine resistant and
trabacteralis
they're kind of you know patient can be
colonized with them and you know there
can be transmission
and so for us it's quite key to get an
identification as quickly as possible so
we've been trying to look at lots of
different methods in terms of
identification and one of the research
methods that we were trying to look at
was actually the mbt star
carber ibd kit and
so again being the international
hospital we get a number of different
patients from all over and
the prevalence of entrop resistant and
vector rallies can be different in
different
countries it can be more prevalent or
less um and so having patients coming
from different uh places to a
centralized international hospital
there is an introduced risk of a higher
risk of introducing carbopenem-resistant
intrabacteries
um and so you know for us it's important
to act quickly
to stop transmission between different
patients transmissions and boards
but also quick identification so you
know treatment can be modified if
necessary
um and so we did look at the mbt carbon
star kit actually to
try and incorporate it within our cpe
algorithm
um one of the key reasons for wanting to
do this is basically infection control
so infection control is a key aspect of
the wars particularly when you've got
patients coming in
that have rare diseases or are you know
specialized and so you know trying to
prevent them from getting more sick you
know neutropenic patients
you know infectious control can act
quickly to either cohort
patients so actually they you know
stopping the spread of
other of cpe to other patients
so because we were quite interested in
this we kind of decided to do
a validation on this kit and analyzing
it on
the moldy tof to see how it worked so
our current method at the moment so we
you we are quite focused on mic
and confirmatory disc testing and we
also do
recently incorporated lateral flow tests
which have helped greatly too but we
still need to kind of make change
um what we're trying to look at in our
laboratory is making
a workflow where we can get a quick
identification of a cpe
quickly so that absolutely infects you
control or
you know the clinician can make a
modification in treatment or in terms of
what happened to that patient
and cohorting them so we carried out a
validation on antibacterials and
pseudomonas and so far we've tested 103
isolates
it showed very good performance and
we've still got a bit more of the
validation to do
and what we're trying to do is look at
how to incorporate it within our cpu
workflow so this is currently you know
when the
scientists own the laboratory doing
their work on the benches
um you know looking at the antibiogram
it's then taking action quickly so
having a diagnostic test where you can
identificate uh resistant cpe quickly or
cpo
we can then you know let infection
control know quickly so that they can
take the necessary action or
clinicians taking necessary action in
terms of treatment modification
so the new cp algorithm is basically to
improve diagnostic workflow
so that a rapid cpa result can be
obtained based on the mbt sexy type ibd
and mbt star bl results
this will be done by designing a new
algorithm which will give a quicker
detection of cp
and negative results so negative results
are just as important as positive
results
and so actually if you know a patient is
negative that contains their treatment
or actually mean they can be discharged
quickly so you know
having that result has an impact i think
also we have to think about the patient
again that you know we
deal with very young children and so
actually you know it can be quite
stressful and to be
kept in a ward or in a closed room and
actually you know if you can discharge a
patient more quickly that's really
really quick so yeah
quicker detection to improve infection
control procedures so that patients can
be isolated quickly to stop the
transmission of an infection but also
negative results meaning you know
discharge as well
so we are looking at a number of other
things as well with the maldives hyper
um so one of the key things we're trying
to look at is also um
direct detection of resistant mechanisms
so we said about cp but also mrsa
so currently with our mrsa workflow we
do
biochemical tests do confirmation with a
capoxitin disk
using newcast guidelines um and also
mics as well but actually you know
if we can get an id more quickly again
that is something that would
be a benefit to our hospital so again a
benefit to infectious control so they
can isolate the patient
but also for our laboratory as well so
what we're currently looking at at the
moment is direct identification of
mrsas from the moldy top directly so
when your culture has grown
to identify through the moldy tof and
then actually get an mrsa result
to follow as well so that actually
you've got that result
and then rather than waiting for a
sensitivity to confirm
that oh you know this is an mrsa
actually having it immediately at that
point
you can inform infection control they
can carry out their procedures
and again that would also save our
laboratory in terms of costs so
we wouldn't necessarily need to do the
cathoxide mic
for new patients because we are
currently i mean we're we're still
looking at our workflow and we
use a carboxylating disc but you know we
also use the catholics in mic as well
um just in case so actually that there
could definitely be a change in terms of
our workflow so uh
just to mention amr precision so this is
a quite an exciting project that we have
in our hospital at the moment
um and it's kind of a partnership with
university college london as well as
some other
hospital trusts in london and basically
we are looking at how to basically
use utilize rapid diagnostics in order
to get
a quick identification to identify
and identify antimicrobial resistance
quickly
so that actually you know we can see
patient benefit definitely patient
benefit so
this is a project that's incorporated
and starting in january and
uh part of this project we'll be looking
at mass specs again
it's used for cpe scpo so carbo
pentameter resistant
and tribeca rallies and organ
carbopylase resistant organisms
also for um mrsa as well
and trying to look at other ways of like
typing as well so we want to
look at it from an infection prevention
control way as well so
you utilizing moldy toddler typing but
again this is something in the future
that we're
looking at and so i think it's quite
exciting to have amr precision
um going ahead from january so we will
be trying to utilize the multi-top even
further
to benefit a patient and see how we can
translate that research
into clinical benefit in the laboratory
so um just to kind of summarize
basically my medical biotype and the mbt
excessive type of iv get has it
benefited great organizational
microbiology well
i've got one art since yes it's really
changed
our workflows greatly um me it's been
eight years and i
remember the kind of resistance and
change from staff when we were bringing
it in but actually
they saw the benefits it changed how
their workflow getting an identification
more quickly
patient benefit you know getting that
results adequately that actually
contains their treatment or infection
control can you know
carry out the necessary uh actions to
isolate that patient
and it's been really really key and so
yeah it's
it really benefited from just
identification of bacterial isolate
to using the mbt sepsi typer
and you know future developments when we
start to incorporate the mbt star
as well so yeah just to kind of
summarize
conclusion of is that basically we have
seen improved antimicrobial prescribing
and this is based on the mbt sepsis typo
and the rapid workflow which you know
is reduced time even great more greatly
and so
results from positive blood cultures can
now be delivered up to 48 hours faster
to the clinician in you know faster
change of therapy
um i've been going all about infection
control but improved infection
controlled by mbt sepsis type
ibd and you know changing bed management
of patients
depending on the identification of the
organism and i think one key thing so
you know i think everywhere there's
always an issue and especially now in
this
current climate with covid there is a
need to
also try and save money where possible
um and so actually you know
there has been a benefit for the
laboratory and for the trust utilizing
uh multitude because we've had a been
able to change our way of thinking
change what tests we do so actually you
know reduce laboratory tests and which
actually is a reduced cost as well
and but also you know from a patient's
eyes reducing use of antibiotics
unnecessary antibiotics
also quicker diagnosis means quicker
action for adopted treatment so patients
can be
stay can be reduced so that's been key
and overall there has been
a patient benefit so i i can't really
stress anymore how
king molly top item has been to our
trust and our laboratory
and you know i it's been so key now but
i'm also excited for the future to see
the future developments particularly
with amr precision as well
um so just for anyone this is just
contact details for
brooker so you know contact your local
representative
for any information you may require um
and that is it for me so thank you very
much for listening to my presentation
thank you frances for your informative
presentation
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
so uh francis how did staff react
to the change in methodology um
so basically the change so i mean uh
when we actually
implemented moldy tough and sepsi type
it was quite a change i mean we had
staff that had been here for a long time
they were very experienced and
very knowledgeable and they were quite
used to you know actually
their kind of uh biochemical tests and
bacterial identification tests
and doing it and they almost felt like
they were being this skilled
but actually once we actually
implemented the moldy tof
got staff involved with the validation
and actually getting it going live they
actually could see the benefits and
actually you know
getting people involved really helped
the process i mean they managed to see
what benefit was to their workflow
actually helped how it
improved workflow in terms of setting up
sensitivities
and so yeah everyone could see the
benefit definitely so i think
initially there was there was some
resistance but then actually as people
eventually got used to it and actually
got involved with the validation they
actually saw the benefits and changes
that i had so yeah
there was an initial resistance but over
time it got better actually everyone
i don't think anyone in the lab could
live without multi-tough now we are so
reliant on it so heavily relying on it
and then i mean we've had times where
the moldy tof has
for example you know it's being serviced
and we've had to go back to
biochemical tests and it's such a change
and actually people realize how reliant
we are on it to get that species
identification
wonderful thank you and so moving on to
our next question
now are you using the sepsa typer for
all samples or only for
uh a select amount of samples so
we are using so so this is just sepsi
typer
um so for the section table we're using
that for blood cultures
so any blood cultures that come up
positive um and it's the first one for a
patient
we would use the sexy type in order to
get that identification
of the organism that's within their
blood
and now are you using sepsa typer over
the complete day
or only during a specific shift
so we're using it 24 7 so
within our laboratory we're actually a
24 7 lab so
there's always a team in during the day
um
and then at basically after in the
afternoon evening time there's only one
healthcare scientist working and then
overnight there was only one healthcare
scientist and so if the blood culture
machine flags that positive
they would go and take that blood
culture off the machine and if it's a
new one they would use that so yeah we
are using it 24
7. so any time um you know three o'clock
in the morning
or late at night we would use a sexy
type of because
then you get an id straight away and
then if we've managed to successfully
get an id
the healthcare scientist will phone the
ward and give that id to the
medic so then they can treat
appropriately
wonderful thank you so so francis if the
positive blood cultures contains
two or more infectious agents does the
maldi-tof distinguish all of them
so i think you you need to get specific
actual
software in order to be able to
differentiate so
our current software isn't we're looking
to move to another one so there is a
sexy type of software which actually
does allow
you to actually identify there are two
different organisms present within blood
cultures
and we haven't looked at that yet but
we're hoping to because i mean yeah
there can be instances where you can
um but currently with just the sepsi
type mbt
yeah yeah you you can't it so it's just
one organism but there is software
available in order to be able to do that
um analysis for two pathogens
okay now did you observe any differences
in the performance of the sepsis hyper
for gram positives and gram negatives
um so it seems grand negatives are
actually more easier to identify so
within even our patient group with
gram-negative organisms we managed to
get id's fairly quickly and quite
easily gram-positive seem a slightly
more difficult i mean
we get very good ideas but it tends to
be that
when there are times where you might get
um
no no peaks or no identification it
tends to be it's a grand positive
organism
usually kind of like the staffed species
but generally yeah gram negatives tend
to i do better
thank you now are moving on to our next
question
does star carba work in your experience
for different
enzymatic excuse my pronunciation
carbopanimase types
yes so from the validation we carry that
we managed to correctly identify the
different either
eyes uh enzymatic type so um
yeah we basically the isolates that we
had tested we had isolates within our
validation which we
tested with other methods and also
they've been sent to the reference
laboratory where they've been tested by
pcr and so we were able to kind of
correctly
identify that way and see that yes
perfect thank you so much for for
answering that question
now did you have any difficulties
validating the method
um no in terms of sepsi type of moldy
top
there wasn't really i mean we just you
had to do an extensive validation i mean
it depends on what organisms or what you
have present so in terms of for the
moldy task
i mean we had lots of bacterial isolates
which have been confirmed by other
methods such as
bacterial identification methods or
we're fortunate we've got 16 spcr
in-house
and also been sent to the reference
laboratory we've also had a number of
external quality assurance sample
which we'd receive from like netclass
for example um and they
we would test those as well so we just
basically before we started the
validation we made sure we had a good
range of samples to validate it
and i mean obviously there are some
organisms which are quite rare which you
might not be able to get hold of so i
mean for our kind of
ah you know so that we're happy we
basically if we get an idea from the
moldy toss
and it's an organism we may have never
heard before we would then refer it for
16 fpcr just to get that confirmation so
yeah validating wasn't difficult but in
terms of actually
um yeah for organisms which are more
rare it's better to kind of
get a confirmation so we i mean it but
anything we might have not seen before
and we send it to 16s and most times
actually it's compact correct so it's
been
pretty pretty good
perfect so we do have time for a few
more questions but i do want to remind
our audience that any questions we are
unable to answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the email address that
you provided
at the time of registration so francis
our next question
how did you differentiate mrsa and maldi
toss
so we haven't done it yet it's something
that we're planning to do basically and
so it's going to be quite a bit of
workflow in terms of actually
um i think it's going to be basically
peak analysis so we're probably going to
try and
make a database um but there is also
kind of new
multitask software available to actually
give you that differentiation
and so i mean it's quite if we if we're
planning to go through
a validation and looking at different
peaks that would be quite extensive and
so
that will be analyzing different um
organisms stuff which you have confirmed
by other methods
and once you've got a database you can
actually run you know
when you're screening for mrsa you can
screen it through that way i believe
um new multitask software is available
that you can actually identify mrsa so
you know when you put your isolate
through it should then be able to tell
you
actually it is a likely mrsa and then
you can just confirm it
so our next question is does a does
sepsa piper also work
for pediatric bottles oh yes
so we basically we we as a specialist
pediatric hospital it we
basically use the sepsis diaper and then
it's worked for
our pediatric bottles so i mean we we
only have children from newborns to
16 years old and yeah it's worked fine
and
we we used both the pediatric aerobic
bottles and an anaerobic bottle
and it's from our performance yeah it's
worked we also validated it so i mean we
used
horse blood and spiked it with control
organism and we did it at different
concentrations as well
so we did serial dilutions just to test
them that worked as well
so
great now so do you perform the full
extraction workflow if you have
no id for the rapid workflow
yes yes so we would start an initial um
with the
rapid workflow but then if we had no id
as long as you've got plenty of pellet
left so i mean we always tried to keep
some
during the process we would go back to
that to then carry out full extraction
just to see
so yeah you would always use your rapid
one just to see that you can actually
get the id
and but then again if you just hold on
to that pellet and
then you can go back to it to do a full
extraction if you're unsuccessful
getting an id
perfect thank you so much francis so we
want to thank
thank you again um do you have any final
comments for our audience
um no i mean i just all i can reiterate
i mean
yeah thinking about i mean making this
presentation and actually thinking back
it's almost like a little history lesson
um and yeah it's
it's amazing to see how microbiology has
changed but particularly how
mass spec has really kind of changed our
laboratory
and i'm sure many other laboratories too
but it really has kind of revolutionized
things and i think
more importantly you know just for
patient care because i'm always thinking
about the patient and how can we treat
them quickly
and so i i think it's yeah i think it's
really revolutionizing so yeah
that's kind of the way i'll end
that was great thank you again francis
so before we go
we would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
you know questions that we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information that you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again
thank francis for his time today and his
important research
we would also like to thank labberts and
our sponsor brooker deltonix for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
labbert will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
if you missed any part of our webinar
series please visit the labyrinths
website
where you can still sign up to watch all
of them on demand
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and until next time
bye bye everyone